Instructor: A set in
JavaScript is like a unique
array, meaning that you can only
ever add the same item once,
with a nice API for managing the
items inside of it. It's
different than an array, in that
you can't access the items
individually and it's not index
based. You can think of a
set as just a list of items,
which we can add to, remove from,
and loop over. Let's take a look
at how it works, how the API
works, and then we'll talk about
looping over it. I can
create a new set by storing it
in a variable, and then you set .
add to be able to add items to
it. Open this up in my
browser and type people. You'll
see that we now have a set. It
looks very similar to an array.
Information about the set, you
can say people.size. It's not .
length, and that's because they
can't be accessed by their index,
so it's .size to get it. You
can list the people. You can
open it up and see what we have
in there. If you'd like to
remove someone, you say people.
delete("Wes"). You don't have to
figure out where the index of
Wes is. With an array, you'd
always have to figure out where
it is. Here, you just delete it,
and people now has two items in
it. We can clear everyone from
the set entirely with set.clear,
and that gives us an empty set.
If I refresh this page here, and
we call one of the other methods,
which is entries, keys or values --
I'm going to call values on it
because it makes the most sense --
what do we get here? We get, in
set iterator it gives us all of
the values, but also, what is a
set iterator? That means that we
can loop over it, or you may
remember from our generators
videos, that this is a generator.
If we stick that thing in a
variable, we can just call next
on it. It.next, it.next, it.next,
it.next, and then we're done.
What that probably means to you
is, "Oh, cool, I can use the
generator API on it with .next
or I could manually feed it
right into a for...of loop."
Refresh and we see Wes Snickers
Kate. The set also has
methods of keys and entries.
I'll show you what that is real
quick. Say people.keys. What's
the difference between keys and
values? Absolutely nothing,
because a set is just values.
Keys and values are mapped to
the exact same thing. Then we
also have .entries, which if you
look at it, Wes, Wes, Snickers,
Snickers, Kate, Kate. These two
ones, keys and entries, those
are really helpful when we
actually get into map. The
reason I think they're there is
that we can have the same API on
map and set, and we don't have
to worry about if it's there or
not. Let's take a look at
another example with some
students. I can say cons.
students = new Set(). Now, if
you want to declare the set with
the values in it while you make
it, you can pass it just like
you would array. You can also
create a set when you pass it an
array. Say we actually have an
existing array. We can take that
array and just pass it into our
new set. Take a look here. We've
got dog set is actually a real
set that's been created from an
existing array. One other
thing we can do is we can use .
has to see if someone is already
in it. Remember we talked about
the set as being unique? If I
were to take these students here,
and I could call .has("Tony"),
it'll say true, .has("Wess")
spelled wrong, gives me false.
If I add someone twice, it's
still going to -- I could add it
a million times -- and the
property of is that it is unique.
One more thing, as I said, you
cannot reference students 1. It
is not an index-based thing. It
is a list, and if you need to
loop over them, you have to use
a for...of loop. That is the
entire set. It's fairly
straightforward. We've got add,
clear, delete, size property, .
has to see if it's in there, and
we can use for...of to loop over
it, or we can manually do it
with the generator by calling .
next on it.